Deals with alcoholism and at the biological level,
that's what I did my phd thesis on and much of my early published papers where I
learned about brain function because alcohol affects every part of the brain.
So I learned a lot about the brain.
What prompted my interest in that area.
And you're a parent shift,
two issues clustered around personality.
While I was always interested in motivation for drug and alcohol abuse,
you know what it was the drove people to use drugs of,
of,
of abuse,
let's say.
And um,
I got the opportunity to study at Miguel under Dr Robert Peel,
who was an excellent supervisor and he was deeply involved with,
um,
drug and alcohol abuse research,
looking at motivation for alcoholism.
And he offered me a position in his lab and,
and that was what he was working on.
And I thought,
well,
that was one of my cardinal interests,
although perhaps not my,
my fundamental interest,
which even at that point had to do with motivation for totalitarianism and the
Commission of atrocity in the service of,
of group belief.
But I thought,
well,
it's a broad topic and I could learn a lot about biology and neurobiology as a
consequence of working on something that was so biological.
So my,
my early work in psychology was extremely biologically oriented and it was
unbelievably useful.
I learned a lot from the animal experimentalists in particular people like
Jeffrey Gray and later Jaak Panksepp.
Um,
I have a reading list at Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom that outlines some of those emotional,
so those books on emotional neuroscience.
Um,
what was my,
why did I shift?
Well there was a variety of reasons.
One was that the National Institute of Alcohol Abuse and alcoholism and I AAA,
which funded grant research in the United States essentially made the corn of
research I was doing with Robert Peale.
Impossible.
And it's part of the consequence.
I think this is one of the things that the universities are doing so terribly
wrong,
is the ethics committees made our research impossible both to fund and to
implement.
So here's why.
So we were bringing people into the lab.
So here's who we pick for subjects.
If you are going to be a subject in one of our experiments,
you had to be a young man and you had to have an alcoholic father and an
alcoholic grandfather and at least one other first or second degree male
alcoholic relative.
Well,
I hope I'm back again.
You know,
my software updated and obviously the update has a bug,
so that's rather annoying.
Um,
apologies for that.
Once again.
So back to the alcoholism discussion.
Um,
where was I?
Oh yes.
So we would get these subjects.
I,
I mentioned who they were,
they were young men who weren't alcoholic,
but who drank socially,
who had an alcoholic father,
an alcoholic grandfather,
and at least one other male alcoholic relative.
Now why did we pick subjects like that?
Well,
we knew alcoholism ran in families and we couldn't really study its transmission
and women because if you're a female alcoholic and you drink when you have a
child in Utero,
then the child can have fetal alcohol syndrome and whatever abnormalities in
psychophysiological response or psychopathologies might be associated with,
uh,
their alcoholism can easily be masked by the presence of fetal alcohol syndrome.
So we couldn't use women and besides alcoholism is a problem that fundamentally
characterized as men.
Although there are female alcoholics,
I think it's four to one if I remember correctly from from those days,
it's four to one male to female,
so it was,
we know when we thought if we concentrated on those who had the highest
probability of developing alcoholism because of their loaded family history that
we could shed some light on the mechanisms associated with alcoholism and that
would be useful for men and for women.
So we studied sons of male alcoholics,
sons of multigenerational male alcoholics.
Those were our target group,
very hard populations to find.
We have people hired full time to do nothing but find us research subjects and
so we did relatively small end studies because we were lucky if we could gather
four or five subjects a month in the Montreal urban area.
Anyways,
we did discover a lot about alcoholism.
We discovered for example,
that if people with this multigenerational history,
a substantial proportion of them,
if they drank enough alcohol to move their blood level up above 0.08 which is
legal intoxication level.
And if they did that relatively short period of time,
then their heart rate would increase above,
I think the average was about 12 beats per minute compared to the standard
control of,
of zero zero or one or two.
It was is very low.
And so,
and then we did figure out over time our whole team that that seemed to be a
consequence of susceptibility to alcohol's effect on opioid production in the
brain.
And Secondary,
uh,
opioid effects on dopamine,
which is both opiates and dopamine are primarily primary reward chemical.
So it looked to us like people with multigenerational family histories of
alcoholism got an opiate response from alcohol.
So,
but we had to get people drunk in order to find this response.
And it turned out that 0.08,
which was the legal limit at that time for driving was approximately the place
where we saw the psychophysiological effects and also saw fairly pronounced
cognitive and motor effects of alcohol because we also studied that.
So now to bring,
we bring people into the lab and we'd give them three large shots of alcohol
that they consumed in 10 minutes.
We use laboratory alcohol,
which was I think 95% pure alcohol,
usually put it in orange juice.
Um,
and so people would be,
you know,
reasonably intoxicated.
And then we would let them sober up until they were at 0.04,
which is half legal intoxication,
which we thought was useful.
And then we put them in a cabin and they'd go home and we,
you know,
we had our odd mishap now and then someone would throw up and that was,
well I'm at least getting better at fixing it when it screws up now.
So um,
you know when it anyways,
now and then we would have somebody who would be becoming all in the lab and
that was always unpleasant.
But then we also let people sober up and it actually takes quite a long time to
go from point a to 0.04,
especially if you're a big guy cause your,
your dose of alcohol is proportionate to your body weight.
And so we used to have people wait in the lab for a couple of hours.
So you know,
and they were not very happy necessarily about having to wait before we paid
them and so forth.
And,
and if we didn't treat them extraordinarily well,
which we tried to do,
then of course they were much less likely to come back and participate in
another study.
And since it was very difficult to get research subjects,
then we wanted to treat them very well apart from the fact that we would have
done that anyways.
But then,
and I AAA said,
well,
you can't let your research subjects go home until they have a blood alcohol
level of point.
Oh two was like,
we would have had to have people in our lab,
you know,
sobering up for
okay.
For six to eight hours.
This keeps happening.
I'm very sorry about this,
everyone.
Okay.
I don't know what to say about it except that that's a consequence of software
updates I suppose.
Um,
anyways,
so that made it impossible because we just couldn't keep people in the lab for
that long.
All it did was annoyed them to death and then they hated us and they,
you know,
people would get quite irritable and upset and no bloody wonder.
So then also,
and I AAA decided that half our subjects had to be women or we couldn't get
funding.
Well,
no,
our subjects couldn't be women.
It was impossible to do the kind of research that we were doing with women for
the reasons that I just don't like.
Well,
first of all,
um,
alcoholism doesn't affect women as much as it affects men.
Depression and anxiety tend to affect women more than it's perfectly reasonable
to study those things.
But that isn't what we were doing.
And,
uh,
and then we couldn't do multigenerational studies for,
for genetic predisposition with women because of the fetal alcohol syndrome
problem.
And you know,
this was something,
I think this came in under the Clintons,
this re requirement for absolute gender equality in,
in subject selection.
And they didn't give a damn if that meant that there were certain kinds of
research that just couldn't be done anymore.
And so I had to stop doing it.
And no one's really doing that kind of research anymore because it's just too
difficult.
It's like it was always a pain because it was really hard to get the subjects
and then you had to get people quite intoxicated and then you had to deal with
them when they were drunk and you had to do your psychophysiological recording
and all that of thing.
And then they had to sober up and you know,
it was complicated.
Clinical research is unbelievably,
unbelievably complicated and difficult.
And then yeah,
I would like to more restrictions to it and people just go,
oh,
okay,
well we,
I guess we won't study the psychophysiological consequences of alcohol anymore
or so people would use low doses,
you know,
and only get their subject's blood alcohol level up to like 0.02 or 0.03 but
that's completely irrelevant because alcohol doesn't have much of a
physiological effect.
It,
those low doses.
And so while this is one of the things that made me absolutely despise ethics
committees,
and I believe that the proliferation of ethics committees is one of the reasons
that university research human research is,
is,
is doing badly.
Psychological research is doing badly.
There's a variety of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them.
So I was interested,
sorry this is a very long answer,
but I was interested in personality as well.
You know,
because I was a clinical psychologist and I'd read Freud and Jung and Adler and
all the great clinicians of the 20th century.
And when I went to Harvard I was offered,
you know,
I,
when you're a new faculty member,
there's usually a set course that they require you to teach.
That's one of the core courses.
And then you have some freedom with your other courses.
And so I said I'd teach personality and then I got more and more and we were
looking at personality models with the alcoholism research too.
At that point,
the big five was starting to establish itself.
And I wasn't much of an admirer of the big five because I like,
while I like theories as well as empirical research.
And I thought the big five,
while there was just no theory at all,
it was just brute force empiricism,
but well,
but you know,
that data eventually became convincing.
And as I got more and more interested in,
um,
in personality,
I got more and more interested in the use of personality and other psychometric
technologies to predict things like academic and creative success.
You see it at McGill,
my Bob and I and a variety of other people were using,
um,
psychological tests of various sorts to predict things like alcoholism and
antisocial personality.
So we could use the big five and neuropsychological tests,
tests of Dorsolateral prefrontal function,
at least in principle,
to predict to some degree who might be susceptible to the development of
antisocial personality.
And then when I went to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
hey,
maybe we could use those tests to predict who was going to be good at things as
well as who was going to be bad.
You know,
the people who are creative are the people who were,
um,
academically,
outstanding or people who did well as managers and administrators and
corporations might do well on personality tests and,
and neuropsychological tests that assess dorsolateral prefrontal functions.
That's higher order cognition.
So we started to put together test batteries that assessed that and that was
fascinating research.
I did that with Daniel Higgins,
who's the partner,
my partner in the development of the self authoring program and understand
myself that things that he's labored for years on before they really became
successful.
Um,
and he wrote a bang up thesis.
I think it was the best thing ever written on this,
on the topic of intelligence.
And,
and launched that he started working on in,
in 1993,
which is about the same time that the bell curve came out.
And so his research actually became row relatively politically contentious,
even though all we were trying to do was trying to determine what attributes
predicted success among creative people and among managers and administrators
and,
and academia and so forth,
pure empirical research.
But it became real,
very rapidly politicized anyways.
So I just got more and more interested in psychometrics,
partly because I realized way back when in 1993 that almost nothing that's
psychologists measured was actually real.
And so we were interested in what was real.
And Daniel is an engineer trained at Mit.
And so he was very,
very method method,
a methodical person.
And he didn't like to move ahead with his research at all,
unless he had nailed absolutely everything down in a way that only an engineer
and a software coder would.
And so we started working on personality models and I've been doing that and
concentrating on that more specifically ever since,
as well as writing the more theoretical material that was associated,
say with 12 rules for life in maps of meaning.